[Musique]
en 2015
je lis un article dans le monde qui aura
sur mon parcours professionnel et
universitaire un impact que je ne
soupçonne pas dans cet article
chris blache experte de la prise en
compte du genre dans les projets
d'aménagement explique que la façon dont
les aménageurs conçoivent la ville est
un vecteur d'inégalité entre les femmes
et les hommes et que la ville comme on
la pense aujourd'hui favorise les hommes
ou du moins les usages dits masculins
elle conclut par une mise en garde si
l'on continue à un visibiliser ces
discriminations la ville durable que
l'on entend construire pour demain
tendra à les accroître
l'aménagement crée des inégalités de
genre à vous qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
peut-être que vous êtes déjà rôdé sur la
question peut-être que c'est la première
fois que vous l'entendez que vous avez
quelques doutes vous n'êtes pas encore
tout à fait convaincu moi à l'époque je
suis une jeune femme de 22 ans en
deuxième année d'école d'ingénieur
spécialisation aménagement et politiques
urbaines et pour tout vous avouer ce qui
est défendu dans cet article me laisse
un peu perplexe en 2015 je suis apprenti
ingénieur urbaniste et je n'ai encore
jamais entendu dire dans ma formation
que l'aménagement mon futur métier
pourra créer quelque chose que j'ai un
peu de mal à supporter de l'inégalité
entre les femmes et les hommes en 2015
je suis une jeune femme de 22 ans et je
n'ai pas particulièrement l'impression
d'être discriminées ou désavantagé dans
la rue et puis je relis les exemples qui
sont donnés dans l'arctique et la
perplexité s'évanouit un petit peu je
n'ai effectivement jamais utiliser les
terrains de sport des espaces publics de
loisirs d'ailleurs plus jeunes avec mes
copines on n'utilisait pas non plus le
terrain de foot de notre cour de
récréation
vous savez le cran
est ce parce qu'ils utilisent en général
pas mal de place je me pose la question
de comment je vais rentrer le soir après
être allé faire la fête
surtout si je dois rentrer tout seul et
je ne me déplace en ville jamais en vélo
le moyen de transport favori de la ville
durable de demain
d'abord parce que je ne sais pas très
bien comment ça marche
et puis parce qu'en fonction de la façon
dont je suis habillé c'est pas toujours
très pratique
finalement grâce à cet article je
réalise aujourd'hui une thèse sur ce
sujet enfin pas tout à fait sur ce sujet
je vous explique me sentant investis de
la mission d'en savoir plus sur les
inégalités genre et de la ville et
pensant avoir trouvé un sujet de thèse
parfait d'actualité et innovant je me
lance je vais regarder dans quelle
mesure la ville et inégalitaire bon sauf
que figurez vous pour tous ceux qui
n'avaient jamais entendu parler de ces
questions là et qu'ils pensaient venir
écouter un talk sur un sujet innovants
je suis désolé mais c'est raté
parce que c'est un sujet d'actualité
déjà depuis un petit moment dans le
monde universitaire les premiers travaux
remontent aux années 1970 et du coup ça
n'a rien de franchement innovant sur les
bons conseils de ma directrice de thèse
j'admets que j'ai plusieurs dizaines
d'années de retard pour mettre en
lumière les inégalités genre et de la
ville d'aujourd'hui est une petite
dizaine d'années davance pour regarder
en quoi la ville durable de demain
tendre à les accroître
je découvre également que ce sujet sort
des laboratoires et a déjà été pris en
compte dans différentes villes
européennes vienne berlin madrid ont
déjà été dites et des guides sur
l'aménagement genre et et explique
comment de prendre en compte ce critère
genre en suivant leur exemple le service
intégration et inclusion de la mairie de
paris publie en 2016 un guide à
destination des aménageurs qui
s'intitule genre et espaces publics les
questions à se poser
et puis en janvier 2018 j'apprends que
c'est autour de la mairie de lyon le
service égalité notamment
de d'entreprendre la rédaction de son
propre guide pour une ville égalitaire
et c'est l'opportunité d'intégrer ce
groupe de travail lyonnais qui a fini de
me convaincre d'étudier comment les
questions de genre et les revendications
sont mises en politique
comment ce souci d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes se diffuse dans
l'action publique urbaine
quels sont les acteurs et les actrices
qui participe à sa promotion
quels moyens ils utilisent et pourquoi
au cours de mes recherches je m'aperçois
que dès les années 1990 les femmes
notamment ont fait entrer les questions
de genre à la table des négociations des
débats internationaux autour des villes
un des lieux les plus célèbres ou et
décider l'avenir des villes ce sont les
conférences habitat organisé par une
habitat lors de la deuxième conférence
habitat en 1996 un groupe de femmes
décident d'eux appelé la super coalition
de femmes fait entrer ses revendications
à l'intérieur de ces débats plus
localement à paris s'est tenue en 1994
une conférence organisée par l' ocde
intitulé les femmes et la ville service
logement et environnement urbain qui a
réuni quand même 17 pays et une
délégation française d'une trentaine de
personnes mais ces préconisations et les
engagements pris lors de ces événements
n'ont pas pris corps dans les politiques
urbaines françaises à ce moment là à la
différence du canada où le réseau
international femmes et ville installe
son siège à montréal et où différentes
mesures de participation inclusive sont
mises en place comme par exemple des
conseils de femmes ou des marches
exploratoires en france il faut attendre
2014 pour que le genre devienne une
priorité de ce qu'on appelle la
politique de la vie est loin de
systématiser la prise en compte de
l'égalité femmes hommes dans tous les
projets d'aménagement
il s'agit plutôt de regarder la place
des femmes dans les quartiers
10 politique de la ville soit les
quartiers populaires la découverte de la
tenue de ces conférences dans des années
90 me pose question en tant que
chercheuse et me déprime un petit peu
pourquoi cela n'a pas peur qu les à
l'époque dans l'action publique
que s'est il passé en 20 ans alors oui
ok vous allez peut-être me dire le
changement ça prend du temps
vous allez peut-être aussi me dire
regard de combien de temps il nous a
fallu pour systématiser la prise en
compte du développement durable au
projet d'aménagement ses tantes et qu'on
y soit parvenu mais j'ai quand même
essayé de creuser le sujet de retrouver
les membres de la délégation française
de la conférence de paris notamment
c'était plus pratique vu que c'était
quasiment à domicile mais sans grand
succès les participants et les
participantes et en soit malheureusement
déjà décédé soit trop âgé pour m'aider
les plus jeunes d'entre eux m'ont
rapidement expliqué qu'il n'avait pas
été assez impliqué pardon dans cette
conférence pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
m'éclairer ou que oui peut-être leur nom
apparaissait dans la liste de la
délégation mais que franchement ce sujet
leur disait rien du tout sûrement et je
cite parce que ce sujet ne devaient pas
intéresser grand monde à l'époque
excusez moi de vous le dire mademoiselle
ok donc un sujet qui n'intéresse
apparemment pas assez pour qu'il soit
mis en politique à cette époque là
dommage on aurait peut-être gagné un peu
de temps mais on en n'a pas perdu tant
que ça sylvette de nef une sociologue
explique qu'un projet d'aménagement
égalitaire
ce n'est pas que la production de
politique urbaine attentive au genre
c'est un projet politique
et d'après elle comme tout projet
politique
il se divise en trois temps le temps de
l'utopie où l'on constate ce qui ne va
pas et où l'on dit ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que ce soit mieux le temps de
la réforme où on va mettre en place un
certain nombre de mesures correctrices
qui vont rester partiel est
insatisfaisante
et puis le temps de là
révolution cette lecture me permet de
considérer l'épisode des années 90 comme
le temps de l'utopie la recherche smith
dans le discours des dirigeants et des
dirigeantes dans le débat autour des
villes
les femmes disent ce qui ne va pas et
explique ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
arranger les choses
aujourd'hui on en serait autant de la
réforme
certes on redit on réécrit ont rétabli
les constats d'il y a vingt ans mais on
produit un certain nombre de mesures des
politiques urbaines genre et ses fameux
guide dont je vous parlais par exemple
mais ces réformes restent partielles
insatisfaisante et pour certains et
certaines des promotrices du genre
contre-productive parfois les débats
liés au harcèlement de rue ont par
exemple donner des arguments à ceux qui
étaient friands de politiques plus
sécuritaire qu' égalitaire et à ce
risque d'instrumentalisation s'ajoute un
risque d' essentialisation dire qu'on
fait des politiques urbaines genre et en
élargissant les trottoirs pour que les
femmes puissent plus facilement se
déplacer en ville en poussette
certes ces pratiques parce que c'est
majoritairement les femmes qui
s'occupent encore aujourd'hui des tâches
de care c'est à dire de prendre soin de
la population des enfants des personnes
âgées ou ayant besoin d'assistance
mais dire cela c'est aussi véhiculer
l'idée que c'est bien le boulot des
femmes trimballer la poussette donc un
temps de la réforme qui est compliqué et
plutôt controversé et ce temps de la
révolution alors malheureusement la
temporalité de ma thèse ne me permettra
pas d'étudier ce temps là s'il a lieu
comme le dit ma directrice camille tu ne
peux pas étudié quelque chose qui
n'existe pas et sans vouloir faire de
plan sur la comète
ce que je peux me demander tout de même
est un des questionnements de mon
travail de recherche c'est si un projet
d'aménagement égalitaire est un projet
politique
de qui
le projet politique s'agite il
aujourd'hui spontanément comme ça je me
dis on parle de la question de la place
des femmes dans l'espace public dont bon
il s'agit il s'agit d'un sujet féministe
ça y est j'ai lâché le mot du coup j'en
profite pour faire une petite parenthèse
et je vous dis ça parce que je sais par
expérience que ce une fois que ce petit
mot est prononcé
il peut avoir tendance à cristalliser
certaine passion et en plus depuis que
je travaille sur ce sujet je suis
devenue la féministe de service et j'ai
eu l'impression pour certaines personnes
c'était quelque chose de péjoratif
j'ai toujours pas bien compris pourquoi
mais du coup j'en profite pour faire une
petite parenthèse qui parmi vous est
profondément contre l'idée d'une égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes une
égalité en droit une égalité dans leur
choix une égalité dans les devoirs
finalement une égalité de chance
quelqu'un personne du coup a priori le
féminisme ça vous connaît un petit peu
donc je peux continuer on parle
d'égalité femmes-hommes de la place des
femmes dans la ville voire même à
travers ce sujet de la place des femmes
dans la société alors dentition je me
dis que le sujet que je traite est un
sujet de féminisme et que les acteurs et
les actrices engagé sur ces questions là
sont des personnes féministe est en
réalité en interrogeant ses acteurs et
ses actrices
je me rends compte que tous ne se
revendique pas féministe et que certes
pour certains leur but finalement c'est
de fabriquer une ville dans laquelle la
vie des femmes seraient facilitées il
m'explique en entretien que cette
fameuse ville les femmes pourront faire
plus facilement ce qu'elles doivent
faire
et ce discours là n'a pas sonné pour moi
du tout comme quelque chose de
féministes on était loin des
revendications de féministes engagées
qui en dénonçant l'utilisation
différencier de la ville
par les hommes et les femmes voulaient
finalement remettre en question
l'attribution contraignante des rôles
sociaux de sexe et de genre
par exemple tu es une femme donc tu dois
faire tel est l activité où tu es un
homme tu dois et tu peux faire telle et
telle démarche
le projet politique derrière une ville
égalitaire de demain n'est donc pas si
évident que cela
l'erreur que j'ai commise sûrement un
petit peu naïvement ça a été d'associer
féminisme et militantisme la prise en
compte du genre dans l'aménagement est
certes un sujet féministe mais il n'est
pas vécue par tous les acteurs qui
participent à la promotion de cette
question là comme une action militante
comme une lutte pour la cause des femmes
et contre l'abolition de l'attribution
contraignantes de ces rôles sociaux pour
les acteurs du monde de l'aménagement
notamment certains d'entre eux le genre
est un outil qui l'ont découvert et
qu'ils ont trouvé intéressant pour
construire la ville de demain
finalement le genre est un outil qui
permet de faire mieux leur boulot et de
répondre aux enjeux actuels des villes
et c'est pour cette raison là
précisément qu'il participe à la
promotion du genre dans l'aménagement
vous l'aurez compris l'objet de ce talk
n'est pas de vous convaincre ou de vous
démontrer par a plus b
en quoi la ville et inégalitaire ni de
vous donner des astuces ou des bonnes
pratiques qui permettraient de faire un
aménagement plus juste mais si j'ai
quand même réussi à attiser votre
curiosité sur cette question je vous
invite à feuilleter les guides bouger
parler ou bien d'aller voir le tedx
champs-elysées ou même de 2018 qui
traite précisément de ces questions là
moi ce que je voudrais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est guetter le temps de la
révolution
elle n'aura peut-être pas la lure que
vous imaginez les revendications
d'égalité s'insère dans tous les
domaines de la société dans
l'aménagement dans l'entreprise dans le
monde du travail
même sur internet une mise en garde
cependant tant que l'on n'aura pas
bouleverser nos mentalités aboli les
stéréo
cheap et tant qu'être un homme ou être
une femme restera quelque chose de
structurant pour le fonctionnement de la
société
toutes les avancées en termes d'égalité
que l'on aura pu faire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui resteront fragiles mais
surtout réversible
alors que vous soyez féministes ou non
militants ou non la prise en compte du
genre nous profitera à tous et à toutes
alors saisissez vous en remercie
[Applaudissements]